that you get to be here and you get to
be paid for your views and you're
telling other women that they shouldn't
be allowed
okay if I may at some stage jumping
um isn't the whole point of being a
feminist though that women are entitled
to have their own views absolutely so
she's perfectly entitled to her views
yeah but you can't you might not like
that but I'm here isn't she exercising
her right as a are you a feminist no I
am not really no you know I wouldn't
have done that part you don't want to be
a feminist no because I think if
feminists it's really believed in
equality but you guys don't I would love
for you there is an oil rig hiring there
is an engineer I would actually love to
see Avis no seriously seriously uh there
is a building being built next to my
building go do it feminists let's go do
it in me I'm staying on the same time
when you find the man you want to get
married to are you saying you will
literally you will be with that man
whatever happens the rest of your life
yes for the vows that we're supposed to
live how do you know you can keep them I
I mean look at I think it's a choice and
that's the thing like women are so
willing to leave marriages because
they're not happy this is not about
happiness the most important thing is
the children and the problem is we have
a modern society where it's me me me my
feelings leave when I feel like it
instead of doing what's best for the
kids either a little say it's a little
butt listening to actually take where
some of it I really don't agree with I
don't agree with the vote stuff when I
have things like that I think there'll
be a lot of people especially older
generation women perhaps who think you
know what she's got a point well I mean
I believe in agency so I think that if a
woman is going to look after her
children the intervals that's absolutely
fine I also believe in your right to
speak your mind about it what I don't
understand
before the 1920s women could speak
openly at this idea that like women
couldn't talk the last 500 years there
have been women throughout the American
States
has been there have been women
throughout history that have read
written and and very influential in
society okay so this idea like women
could never do it what I don't
understand though is when it gets
spiteful okay because you put down a few
arguments that I think are perfectly
like you know they're kind of
Evangelical in their Christian but those
are your right to say what I don't
understand is when it kind of seeps into
this sort of you call women fat you say
that they shouldn't have other questions
the question is are they fat yes or no
woman is 170
that's objectively over one I mean let's
be honest we're not we now celebrate
morbid obesity as some kind of body
positively and it is complete nonsense
so actually on that point again there's
a bit of Truth and this is the problem
this is the problem have we come to
celebrate morbid obesity is body
positive nonsense we're not talking
about more believes I was actually
watching your podcast earlier and you
you spoke to someone who was I would say
probably a size 12 and you called her it
fat a beast and a divorce say she was
fat obesity I mean like I don't know
what to say this is the thing women we
don't want to live in reality we don't
want to say things that are true was she
fat yes was she a divorce say yes these
things are just objective facts okay I'm
gonna have to objectively she insulted
me first they always do I'm gonna have
to objectively end the debate but it was
an interesting conversation I think we
should get you two back together as a
matter of urgency uh thank you very much
Pearl thank you over